- So what would you lovely
people like to hear a rap about?
- [woman] Donner party!
(crowd groans)
- I heard the second word was party,
I misheard the first word, what was it?
- [Woman] The Donner Party.
- As in doner meat?
(crowd murmuring, laughing)
So this sounds like an in joke
that everyone is aware of, so.
(crowd laughing)
You'll need to explain, so, to me,
doner is a type of lamb kebab meat, right?
(crowd laughing)
- [Man] Close, you're close.
- Okay, so would you care to explain?
- [Woman] So there was a
party that was stranded
and then they ate each other.
- A party that was stranded
and ate each other.
Okay, and where did this happen?
(crowd murmuring)
Wow, a lot of people, a lot of
people have opinions of this,
this man over here said Sierra Nevada?
Okay, and why were they
stranded, plane crash?
Oh, in the, in the old time, okay, cool.
Cool, so regional American history.
By the way, that is a very good suggestion
if you want to catch a British person out.
(crowd laughing)
You know, usually people go with
something like Lou Gehrig or some kind of
sports person I'd never
have heard of, but no,
the Donner Party, who were
apparently some gold miners
who were trapped and then decided to eat,
I mean, I guess not decided, like,
were probably forced to,
it probably wasn't like a,
"Well, that's been about an hour
"without any contact, let's eat Kevin."
(crowd laughing)
Great, Donner Party.
That is a great suggestion,
I like it very much.
Let's come to this, you guys over here.
What do you want a rap about?
There's a hand up there, yeah, so polite.
- [Woman] Guys with beards.
Guys with beards!
- Guys with beards, very imaginative
based on the person that
you're sat right next to.
Also quite mean based on the
lack of any hair on my chin,
and I haven't shaved for
two and a half weeks, so.
Guys with beards, what, let's kind of
just push that a bit further.
Is there anything particular,
what is it about guys with beards?
- [Woman] Uh, they wear flannel,
and they drive Tacomas and Tundras.
- They, (laughing) they
ride into tundra, okay.
Guys into beards ride into
- [Woman] Have a Toyota truck.
- And they, they have trucks.
- [Woman] Yeah.
Okay cool, nice, nice.
I love that you just
mimed a truck by going,
I mean, really that's the mime
for vehicle isn't it, right?
That's truck, right?
(crowd laughing)
Guys with beards, they have
trucks, the Donner Party.
Let's come to the middle
front of the room,
what do you want a rap about?
(crowd shouting)
One, one second.
I didn't quite hear it,
but I will come to you,
but this lady very politely
put a hand up here.
- [Woman] Volleyball!
- Volleyball. Okay.
Let's pick a specific thing
about volleyball though,
because I don't take the
same suggestion twice
and three weeks ago in Australia,
a nine year old girl said volleyball.
So I can't take that exact suggestion,
but what I can do is get
you to kind of expand on it.
- [Woman] Competition in volleyball.
- Competition in volleyball, I like it.
That is a good suggestion.
You shouted something out, what was it?
- [Woman] Oh, I said side out.
- You said sign out?
(crowd shouting)
Side out, you know just
you saying side out
doesn't mean anything to me.
(crowd laughing)
Oh, it's a volleyball term, okay, cool.
We can, we can put it into that.
Side out, what a rubbish term that is.
Right.
(crowd laughing)
Yeah, I think I got a
lot of people on board.
They're like, yeah, we should rename it.
Okay so, competition
volleyball and side out,
guys with beards and their trucks,
the Donner Party, we need
two more suggestions.
I'll come to the back, yeah,
you got your hands up there.
- [Woman] Transformational
journey into the hybrid cloud.
- Transformational journey
into the hybrid cloud.
You and one person is
super happy about that.
I am not even going to attempt
to ask you to explain that because
I'm not sure anyone here
knows what any of that means.
Let's get one final one from anywhere.
This has to be really good though.
- [Woman] A guy in a
dumpster behind the Vatican.
- A guy in a dumpster behind the Vatican.
Do you know something
we don't, have you sent?
Have you sent a contract
killer to Vatican City?
Okay, cool, those are
some great suggestions.
I mean mainly you did the heavy lifting,
and you start us off really well.
In the middle we definitely
sagged a little bit.
So, to remind you all, the Donner Party,
guys with beards and the
fact they drive trucks,
competition in volleyball,
maybe including side out,
a transformational journey
into the hybrid cloud,
and yes, I'm quite
impressed I remembered that,
(laughing) and a guy in a
dumpster behind the Vatican.
This then, lovely people
of The Comedy & Magic Club,
little treat for you guys,
a little thing called a freestyle rap.
That is a rap made up on the spot
based entirely on those suggestions.
Do not worry, it will not be
anywhere near as atrociously,
embarrassingly, toe curlingly bad
as you were expecting a privately educated
middle class white boy to be.
(crowd cheering)
Hey friends, it's me
wearing the same clothes,
but with slightly longer
hair, because time passes.
I just launched a challenge
where I want to see you guys rap.
There are details on screen right now,
but also a link to a video
that explains it more fully.
I cannot wait to see what
you guys come up with.
Now, back to the video.
Let's drop that beat my
friend, and have some fun.
(crowd cheering)
And turn it up for me as
well, I got you a real nice
West Coast beat, it's gonna be great.
I like that you guys are getting on board,
you're like, "Oh, we like
the g-funk bass, nice."
♪ Kick it off, yeah, don't
know what I'm talking about ♪
♪ Let me serve, let me spike ♪
♪ Let me get a side out,
what the heck is that ♪
♪ Now the balls no longer in play ♪
♪ But when it's on the
volleyball court I holds weight ♪
♪ I'm the best when it comes
to scoring those points ♪
♪ If you're coming up to
me, I dislocate joints ♪
♪ I break your arm, I break
your shoulder and your hip ♪
♪ Cause when I'm playing
competition, yeah I never slip ♪
♪ I get so angry, I get the red rise up ♪
♪ I'm gonna make sure that I slice it up ♪
♪ I'm going to cut you down
with my volleyball skills ♪
♪ Competition volleyball,
yeah it gives me thrills ♪
♪ Some people say you should
play it the amateur way ♪
♪ I'm like no, I'm a pro,
y'all should go away ♪
♪ When I'm out on the beach,
not inside, you can see me ♪
♪ Even though I'm a guy,
I'm rocking the bikini ♪
♪ Showing everybody I've got great pecs ♪
♪ I'm holding them up,
and then I go who's next ♪
♪ I get a little hungry, so I'm in need ♪
♪ Of getting a whole mouth
full of human protein ♪
♪ I'm a cannibal, yeah I might alarm ya ♪
♪ I'm gonna chow down on you
like I'm Jeffrey Dahmer ♪
♪ He would take people and
put them in the fridge ♪
♪ But back in the days,
yeah, I'll spit about it ♪
♪ The Donner Party down in the gold mine ♪
♪ They would get out and get
a crystal, have a good time ♪
♪ And then suddenly, where's
the transport, oh no ♪
♪ In a difficult position we are caught ♪
♪ Who will we eat first,
look at the sleeves ♪
♪ This guy's quite skinny,
and this guy Steve ♪
♪ Was really fat, so
definitely the first to go ♪
♪ We get him down, oh
Steve, I'm sorry, bro ♪
♪ Then we take a knife and
fork, take the silver there ♪
♪ Giving it down in his
belly, he's not aware ♪
♪ Because we killed him first,
yeah we did it really good ♪
♪ Hung him upside down to
drain the meat off the blood ♪
♪ You don't want all the stress proteins ♪
♪ Getting in the blood out
of his whole bloodstream ♪
♪ It's not nice to make
light of eating people ♪
♪ But, when you're in the
desert, yeah it's all equal ♪
♪ Out in Sierra Nevada,
I know I'd rather ♪
♪ Eat my brother before
my mother or my father ♪
♪ Cause he's fat too,
slightly overweight ♪
♪ When I take anybody on a dinner date ♪
♪ I say come in, it's
got plus ones allowed ♪
♪ Gonna have a transformational ♪
♪ Journey into the hybrid cloud ♪
♪ No one even knows what it mean ♪
♪ But maybe if you're
on the Elon Musk team ♪
♪ Hybrid, like a Toyota Prius ♪
♪ Maybe that's a car
driving on the freeway ♪
♪ It's so amazing when
you see the engine work ♪
♪ But this seems more
different when shouted by her ♪
♪ Cloud storage like it's up in the air ♪
♪ Like the precipitation
raining down without a care ♪
♪ Really no definition, not
this, you might learn me ♪
♪ Later, but I feel the
transformation journey ♪
♪ Is one in this situation, ♪
♪ I explore myself, interior meditation ♪
♪ Drink some kombucha, grow my hair out ♪
♪ Then I go back, yeah,
this is what I'm about ♪
♪ Having so much fun,
yeah, never even plan ♪
♪ Make it up as I go,
I'm off to the Vatican ♪
♪ Such a small city, a large property ♪
♪ Population condensed so properly ♪
♪ And over here, yeah, what is in ♪
♪ I open it up, I look
inside the trash bin ♪
♪ I know in America, different
words you planned for ♪
♪ You wouldn't wouldn't call it a skip ♪
♪ You would call it a dumpster ♪
♪ I look in there, I say me, oh my ♪
♪ Out of there comes a very
stinky, long haired guy ♪
♪ Who the heck are you, is
this some kind of joke ♪
♪ No, I'm Ratzinburger, the old Pope ♪
♪ I was kicked out of the Vatican palace ♪
♪ Because the new one came
along and he said I'm ♪
♪ Very malicious towards
you, and so you go ♪
♪ Down with all the recycling, ho ho ♪
♪ Kicked me out of the
spire, out of the cupola ♪
♪ That's the real
architectural reference there ♪
♪ If you've been, that's no joke ♪
♪ They pick a new Pope, got
the white and the black smoke ♪
♪ Vatican City, it's very
small, but very pretty ♪
♪ If you see a guy in the
dumpster, probably smells shitty ♪
♪ Stay away from him,
because he pongs a bit ♪
♪ Maybe he's a guy and if you bit him ♪
♪ Then you would spit it out again ♪
♪ It wouldn't taste very fresh ♪
♪ Last one, yeah it's easy to guess ♪
♪ Why you said beard on a
man cause to your left ♪
♪ A guy is sat there and he does select ♪
♪ To never shave, just
grow his facial hair ♪
♪ What car does he drive, a Tundra ♪
♪ Apparently it's not a
car, you can look it up ♪
♪ It's a brand of Toyota,
that thing's a truck ♪
♪ You can ride it along,
like this, not this ♪
♪ You got bristle burn on
your face when you kiss ♪
♪ At night, it's one thing
that I have always feared ♪
♪ That even when I'm 60,
I'll never grow a beard ♪
(crowd cheering)